Tesla it burns cash trashes sales
targets and wants to buy a sister
company SolarCity that does more of the
same big oil should be terrified why one
word capital investors are pouring it
into Tesla while they're asking for it
back from the likes of Exxon ExxonMobil
and its peers still rake in
mind-boggling amounts of cash
despite the all crash and the
International Energy Agency estimates
the oil industry needs to invest 1
trillion dollars every year to meet
future demand in theory investors should
want Big Oil to be big spenders yet
shareholders want their capital back
from big oil in the form of dividends
rather than see it plowed back into the
ground so Big Oil is doing just that
their spending is heading down not up
Tesla meanwhile gets a free pass despite
negative cash flow investors want it to
keep spending CEO Elon Musk has talked
of spending tens of billions of dollars
more on ever more ambitious projects
analysts stop forecasting higher
earnings for Tesla around the end of
2014 the stock didn't really notice
Tesla has shrugged off the losses of
rampant spending every time it sold new
shares in four of the past five years
buyers stepped up there's an analogy
with another threat to the majors shale
drillers despite crushed share prices
and a slew of bankruptcies many of these
smaller oil producers have kept going
aided by willing investors ready to buy
more of their stock could Tesla crash
eventually sure will more shale drillers
go bust undoubtedly but even if they do
others will pick up where they left off
enough investors believe electric
vehicles and shale drilling promise
growth and want to fund it the oil
majors just can't say the same